[Music]
thank you
J.R.R Tolkien builds a great extended
culinary metaphor right into the heart
of his essay on fairy stories and
there's a number of elements to this he
talks about a soup and bones that you
derive the soup from he'll also talk
about broth or stock he uses the term
pot or cauldron and then he also talks
about Cooks so this is an extended
well-developed literary metaphor he's
almost modeling for us how to use
metaphors thoughtfully that is not to
completely believe in them as if they
answer everything but to find where the
similarities the connections that reveal
important features important truths to
us lie and he's going to be again from
somebody else and in a certain way this
also exemplifies what he's talking about
as you'll see in just a moment so he
brings up this person descent and he
says in that sense words I would say we
must be satisfied with the soup that is
set before us and not desire to see the
bones of the ox out of which it has been
boiled and he's using this to talk about
people who are primarily focused on the
origins of fairy stories and bring in
all sorts of considerations and are
looking at the elements and the history
and you know the diffusion and the
borrowings going on and lose sight of
what the actual story is and whether you
could say the soup tastes any good
they're they're focused on the bones
that the stock has been prepared from
and they lose sight of what a soup
actually is and then he goes on and says
oddly enough descent by the soup meant a
mishmash of bogus prehistory founded on
the early surmises of comparative
philology and by desire to see the bones
he meant to demand to see the workings
and proofs that led to these theories by
the soup I mean the story as it is
served up by its author or teller and by
the bones its sources or material even
when by Rare luck these can be with
certainty discovered so Tolkien is
saying I'm taking this person's rather
thin metaphor and I'm going to expand
upon it and here's how I'm changing the
reference the significance of these
terms so the soup you know that we
should appreciate is the story that's
put before us now not every soup is
great as we're going to see the bones
are the
pieces of History you could say that are
encompassed and Incorporated within it
and you don't actually need to see the
bones you know you don't have to go poke
around in the kitchen in order to
appreciate the soup I suppose in our day
of celebrity chef culture maybe some
people feel that they need to but those
are the people who are kind of a pain in
the rear to anyone with a genuine
culinary background
now he does say one thing here
finishing up this paragraph I do not ask
I do not of course forbid criticism of
the soup as soup so it's perfectly fine
to say that a story is not a good story
even if it has great Antiquity behind it
it might not be a particularly
interesting engaging uh revealing fairy
tale so Tolkien is taking this metaphor
originally from descent and putting it
into the very kind of pot that he's
going to be talking about in a moment so
a little bit later after he's talked a
bit about uh Thor and the faces of fairy
tales he says Let Us return to the soup
I mentioned above speaking of the
history of stories and especially fairy
Stories We may say that the pot of soup
The Cauldron of story has always been
boiling and to it have continually been
added new bits dainty and undainty if
you've ever prepared stock yourself
you know that not everything that's
going into it is visually aesthetically
appealing but it's going to make a great
stock you know you put the leavings and
peelings and hind ends and skins of
things and all those bones from the
carcass into it and you get this
wonderful Savory thing and then you
might add some other ingredients after
you've you've got a good stock going now
notice what he's saying here though
this this pot this cauldron has always
been boiling and to it has been
continually added new bits so this
paying attention to this metaphor can
help us to not fall into an immediate
trap which would be to say oh well
there's Eternal archetypes and you know
the the pot of soup has always been
boiling with exactly the same stock no
no that's not true at all
token thinks that there is a development
over time and that sometimes new bits
are added in and they
become part of the the new stock the new
flavor the new soup right and they can
be served up in different ways so it's
not some you know there's the error of
thinking that the ingredients the
original ingredients make the soup
without the process of you know working
it through then there's the while the
soup has always been the same and it you
know just shows up differently in
different cultures and different times a
sort of mistake on the other end the
soup is in the middle the soup is
something that we do add something to
from time to time and other things are
broken down so
he thinks that there's mistakes that get
made by those who are preoccupied with
Origins and he considers a number of
interesting examples any you know brings
out some important points along the way
so the first one he talks about is the
goose girl uh and he says to take a
casual example the fact that a story
resembling the one known as the goose
girl is told in the 13th century of
birth of Broadfoot mother of Charlemagne
proves nothing either way it neither
proves that the story was in the 13th
century descended from Olympus or Asgard
by way of an already legendary King of
old on its way to become a house
American a fairy tale right nor that it
was on its way up the story is found to
be widespread unattached to the mother
of Charlemagne or any other historical
character from this fact by itself we
can we certainly cannot deduce that it
is not true of Charlemagne mother though
it is the kind of deduction that is most
frequently made from that kind of
evidence the opinion that the story is
not true of birth of Broadfoot must be
founded on something else on features in
the story which the critics philosophy
does not allow to be possible in real
life so that he would actually believe
the tail even if it were found nowhere
else or on the evidence of on the basis
uh the existence rather of good
historical evidence that Bertha's life
was quite different so that he would
believe the tale even if his philosophy
allowed it was perfectly possible in
real life and Tolkien is saying you
don't have that so let's be a little bit
leery about making these super broad
generalizations without a hell of a lot
of evidence about precisely where this
story Motif came from
that he talks about a interesting
example much closer to our own time one
that he imagines he says no one would
discredit a story that the Archbishop of
Canterbury slipped on a banana skin
merely because he found that a similar
comic mishap had been reported of many
people and especially if Elder elderly
gentlemen of dignity right
he might disbelieve the story if he
discovered that in an angel or even a
fairy had warned the Archbishop he would
slip if he wore Gators on a Friday he
might also just believe the story if it
was stated to have occurred in the
period between say 1940 and 1943 right
but there's no reason to automatically
dismiss the story of the Archbishop of
Canterbury at some point in time in some
indeterminate way slipping on a banana
peel just because so many other people
had done so up until that time and
continued to do so after that time
then he talks about a really interesting
case
King Arthur about which there's an
entire literature right he says that
um you know these these stories get
added to the the pot in fact got into
the soup new bits added to the stock a
considerable honor for in that super
many things older more potent more
beautiful comic or terrible than they
were in themselves with these first two
stories and then he says Arthur
once historical was also put into the
pot there he was boiled for a long time
so Arthur goes into the pot of story and
there you know probably was a historical
Arthur who was resisting the Saxons and
all that but so many other elements are
already in there
he says he was boiled together with many
other older figures and devices of
Mythology and fairy and even some other
stray bones of History such as Alfred's
defense against the Danes and we might
even think about the you know legendary
impossible meeting between Arthur and
Charlemagne that's in some of the the
Arthurian stuff and then what happens he
says that Arthur emerged as a king of
fairy right so this is a quite an
interesting example Arthur we're not
talking now just about a story we're
talking about an entire cycle of stories
spanning centuries in their Development
coming out of the pot and this is where
the cooks are going to be quite
important we'll come back to that in
just a moment he also talks about
hrothgar Grendel and Beowulf right he
says that these were all in the pot as
well the situation is similar in the
Great Northern Arthurian Court of The
Shield Kings of Denmark the skilleding
US of ancient English tradition King
hrothgar and his family have many
manifest marks of true history far more
than Arthur yet in the earliest in the
older English accounts of them they are
associated with many figures and events
of fairy story they've been in the pot
right and so frothgar has been in the
pot so has Grendel the intrusion of the
ogre into the Royal Hall of hrothgar as
is uh Beowulf himself as he's going to
say at one point he also brings up uh
the story of feruaro and ingel by way of
saying well by the way that reminds me
of this and what is this kind of story
it's you could say star-crossed lovers
right it could also be the story of
Tristan and solda could be much much
later on the story of Romeo and Juliet
right where you have people who fall in
love with each other and they're not
supposed to and it doesn't turn out well
for them in general and he even brings
up that the gods do this at least in I
mean it does happen in other mythologies
but he's talking talking about Norse
mythology where every once in a while a
God will
fall in love with somebody they're not
supposed to and vice versa a giant right
one of the forces of evil and he tells
us that in all of these cases
these stories these figures these
interesting elements have been added to
the pot and boiled something developed
out of them and now you know if we think
about this metaphor of the pot so the
pot would contain many many stories in
that soup how do you actually get
something out of it
here's where he tells us if we speak of
a cauldron we must not wholly forget the
cooks there are many things in The
Cauldron but the cooks do not dip in the
ladle quite blindly their selection is
important right the gods are after all
gods and it's a matter of some moment
what stories are told of them so we must
freely admit that A Tale Of Love is more
likely to be told of a prince in history
indeed is more likely actually to happen
in the historical family whose
Traditions are those of golden Fray and
of Honor than those of Odin the goth and
The Necromancer glutter of crows lord of
the slain and so you know what you pick
out of the pot determines what kind of
story you can tell but as a cook as a
chef you might even say
you determine
what parts of the soup are going to be
put before somebody and what you might
add yourself to that stock to that broth
to that nice stew as he calls it in
other places so the the the
author the reciter is very important in
this and at the very end of this section
he tells us that you know all too often
what one of the things that we forget is
the effects of what these fairy tales
produce
produced Now by these old things in the
stories as they are and he talks about
something quite interesting here he
actually brings up one element that is
culinary namely
um here we go the cannibal Feast right
in the juniper tree and he says that
without the stew in the bones
which children are now too often spared
in mollified versions of grim Grim is
you know the the brothers collecting
these fairy tales and if you've ever
read the Grimm's Fairy Tales which I
strongly advise you to do
they are pretty raw and sometimes
enigmatic in what's going on you know by
contrast to say Disney Cinderella the uh
evil stepsisters wind up doing damage to
their own feet trying to get them into
the glass slipper they cut off their
heels that's kind of gruesome right
that's what Tolkien is going to call
fairies fairy tale horror but he says I
wasn't really harmed by this as a matter
of fact I think it's actually good to
have that within the stories without the
stew and the bones the vision would
largely have been lost
he says that these stories now have a
mythical or total unanalyzable effect
and affect quite independent of the
findings of comparative folklore and one
which it cannot spoil or explain they
open a door on another time and if we
pass through though only for a moment we
stand outside our own time outside time
itself perhaps so this we move from one
metaphor to the other but eating the
soup eating a good soup is part of what
fairy tales actually allow us to do good
fairy tales not the based versions of
them that have essentially lost the
magic or enchantment or if you like the
Savor and the flavor that was originally
in the soup as it was once served